[Music]
[Music]
here in this video we will showcase to
you all an updated ancient history and
timeline of the mcu which will include
all the old events from the new movies
and the mcu series there have been quite
a few videos done on movie timelines
which only talked about captain america
onwards but here we will begin with the
celestial's origins their creation of
the universe the dark elves who existed
before the universe began as god in
history eternals and up till the 17th
century where we see the trial of agatha
harkness which sets up the story for
wonder vision so let's get to it
before 13.8 billion years ago the dark
elves originate from the vast primordial
darkness that existed prior to the
creation of the manifest universe where
they reigned absolute and unchallenged
before 13.8 billion years ago it is
unknown as to the exact origins of the
celestials but since they created the
current cosmos they must be older than
the thing they created their creator is
yet unknown
13.8 billion years ago celestials
created the universe bringing light from
the darkness and created the first stars
planets and solar systems essential for
life to arise
13.8 billion years ago
infinity stones are created before the
universe began six singularities existed
the big bang then formed concentrated
crystals out of them and sent the six
stones hurling throughout the universe
after 13 billion years ago it is unknown
as to the exact timeline but the grand
master and the collector are born
sometime after the creation of the
universe making them one of the oldest
entities ever
4.5 billion years ago planet earth and
the sun are created by the celestials
with the main objective of sealing the
planet in the future with a nasan
celestial seed
approximately one billion years ago the
deviants are created and they are
genetically engineered by the celestials
to ensure the development of sentient
life forms on the planet seeded with
celestial seeds by wiping out the
planet's apex predators
500 to 1 billion years ago the eternals
were built and programmed by the prime
celestial they were sent to planets with
implanted celestial seeds with orders to
protect and help evolve sentient
life-forms after the failures of the
deviants
around 80 million years ago a member of
the ancient primordial race known as
celestials issan the searcher came to
the possession of the power stone and
used it to destroy a planet filled with
life
50 to 80 million years ago ego awakes
and he came into existence as a
flickering brain-like organism perilous
and bottlers floating a drift in the
vacuum of space alone slowly
manipulating the molecules around him
for millions of years to become a planet
2.5 million years ago vibranium falls
onto the earth a meteorite made of
vibranium the strongest substance in the
universe struck the continent of africa
affecting the planned life around it it
became the basis of the future state of
wakanda
one million years ago the exact date is
yet unknown but the creep probably
became a space-faring race and started
to become an empire during this time
also known as cree year one
more than 50 000 bc even though the
eternals arrived on earth 7000 years ago
in the past the celestial seed is
planted on earth way before that
probably in the range of fifty thousand
years before them
ten thousand to twenty thousand bc crow
and a group of deviants are trapped in
the ice in the northern hemisphere as a
result of impending ice age they are
trapped for centuries until before the
events of eternals and the emergence of
tiamat
10 000 bc wakanda is formed as a result
of five tribes of men settling near the
ancient vibranium meteorite crater
wakanda develops technology faster than
any other empire country or state during
that time
7353 bc the s guardian royal family was
established by the asgardian buried the
first king of asgard during the reigns
of its early kings asgard earned a
reputation as the keeper of the peace
within the nine realms
5700 bc agamotto the first sorceress
supreme of earth created and founded the
masters of the mystic arts and began
training humans in the study of magic
and later discovered the time stone and
created the eye of agamotto
5000 bc the synthetic beings known as
eternals arrive on earth in their
spaceship called the domo and they
arrive to protect humans from the
deviants and ensure the future emerges
of tirmouth in the future
3460 bc a young odin defeats serta in
battle the fire demon would then spend
nearly 5 500 years to recover in
muspelheim before his encounter with
odin's son thor in 2017
2988 bc the convergence led to malekith
and a dark elves attempting to use the
reality stone to turn the universe back
into darkness but was stopped by
asgard's armies in the battle of
svatelheim
2000 to 3000 bc in this timeframe
another realm called tallow that existed
in the pocket universe prospered and
achieved a great degree of development
in civilization and technology
2000 bc the people of tallow prospered
in peace until a dweller in darkness who
is a monstrous dark entity and his army
of soul eaters attacked and nearly
escaped into the earthly realm
659 bc
in this year the subjugation of the nine
realms was started it is a conflict
orchestrated by odin heller and their
army in an attempt to conquer the nine
realms and establish an asgardian empire
575 bc the battle of babylon in ancient
mesopotamia
during the neo-babylonian empire it was
fought between the eternals and the
swarm of deviants who preyed on the city
due to its continued expansion and
development
79 a.d in the events of loki the series
loki and mobius time travel and witness
mount vesuvius the eruption and
confirming the theory that interferences
of time traveling in such an impending
doom would not change the timeline
950 a.d the massacre of the valkyrie was
the result of a clash between the
valkyries and heller who sought to
escape her banishment in hell the battle
resulted in the death of all but one of
the valkyries
964 a.d the frost giants with the
cascade of ancient winters began to
attack the nine realms and also earth in
townsburg thereby incurring the wrath of
asgard ending with their defeat in the
battle of gertenheim
1000 ad roughly a thousand years in the
past the skrulls refused to submit to
kree ideologies and thus was the
beginning of the skrull cree war that
still reaches on till this day
13 16 a.d roughly in this year the
ancient one was born she would later
become the sorcerer supreme and used
powers from the dark dimension in order
to stay alive for 700 years
1521 a.d eternals witnessed the fall of
the aztec empire by the spanish invaders
it was also during this conflict that
they believed to have killed the last
deviant until present day when the
deviants frozen in ice re-emerged
1693 a.d trial of agatha harkness in
salem who used dark magic occurred but
this turned sideways and the other
witches who imprisoned her their powers
were in fact absorbed by agatha and they
were all killed in the event
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video on the ancient history and the
timeline of the mcu anyway with that we
come to the end of it so do hit that
like button for support and subscribe as
well to be a part of the mind cue family
but most of all smash the bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam